gardez la france au fond des yeux
j'aimerais beaucoup qu'ils en apprennent
à tricoter d'accord là dessus à votre
place je la ramène un peu moins mais si
vous ne réussissez pas c'est qu'il vous
manque qu'une seule chose un tout petit
détail le trophée des valises à paris de
ce qui lui arrive à la baisse
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
l'inattendu l'émission qui décrypte
l'actualité grâce aux archives de la
télévision
aujourd'hui nous sommes à l'institut de
sondage ipsos nous allons donc parler
chiffre est politique c'est ici que sont
fabriquées les sondages de la
présidentielle de ce fait c'est donc une
revue de presse tout en sondages
aujourd'hui que nous ont préparés
géraldine corner lavaud et ludivine
lopez bonjour ailleurs les deux alors
vous géraldine c'est un sondage paru
dimanche dernier sur l'âge de départ à
la retraite qui vous a interpellé
effectivement un sondage où 71 % des
français se disent favorables à un
retour à la retraite un départ à la
retraite à 60 ans alors le départ à la
retraite à 60 ans c'est la promesse de
deux candidats jean luc mélenchon ou
encore fabien roussel mais cette
retraite gaston massat gauche dont quito
des promesses à gauche sur le 60 ans
sans condition 1 mais la retraite à 60
ans et bien ça a existé souvenez-vous
c'était en 1983 la retraite à 60 ans en
france l'accord a été officiellement
signé ce matin par tous les syndicats y
compris la cgc les cadres qui ont au
dernier moment accepté d'apposer leur
signature au bas de cet accord la
retraite à 60 ans c'est fait
ce sera une grande date dans notre
histoire sociale c'est une vieille
revendication
rivière qui se trouve satisfaite elle va
ajouter de la vie aux années nous
reprendre l'expression du président de
la république à tous ceux qui ont bien
mérité le droit à disposer librement de
leur temps à partir du 1er avril
prochain donc tous les plus de 60 ans
qui le désirent pourront partir en
retraite dès cette date ce sont 140
mille salariés qui pourraient bénéficier
de cette mesure et des 85 ils seraient
plus de 360 milles à partir chaque année
alors rappelons que depuis 2010 l'âge
légal de départ à la retraite de 62 ans
alors autre sondage avait voulu divine
une enquête sur le cyber harcèlement une
enquête parue il ya quelques jours oui
une étude ipsos a un qui révèle sa tombe
bien et ça tourne bien effectivement
quatre internautes sur dix ont déjà été
victimes de cyber violence alors injures
menaces usurpation d'identité le
phénomène est massif d'après les
enquêtes il toucherait principalement
les femmes et les minorités alors à la
télévision on parle de cyber harcèlement
depuis une vingtaine d'années environ
mais les harceleurs malheureusement
n'ont pas attendu internet pour sévir
avant c'était par courrier exemple en
1976 à crépy-en-valois dans l'oise cela
fait maintenant trois ans que l'une de
ses façades la bri celui que l'on
appelle plus que le corbeau de crépy en
valois comment pourrait-il être
étrangers à la ville ce corbeau qui
semble si bien connaître ceux à qui il a
décidé de nuit il a trois ans ils
envoient par la poste un faire-part
annonçant une naissance dans une famille
où la jeune femme qu'il fait parvenir
des dragées et un berceau ne peut avoir
d'enfant sans doute le plaisir de
blesser davantage un choeur déjà meurtri
l'enquète n'aboutit pas l' affaire est
classée le corbeau continue à manier la
plume et les plaintes à s'accumuler à la
gendarmerie la femme d'un médecin reçoit
depuis trois mois des lettres d'amour
avec des allusions très précises à des
souvenirs communs aussi récent qu'intime
haut il ya plusieurs hypothèses lune
c'est que c'est ce qu'on appelle le
mauvais plaisant avec toute la le
mauvais goût qui a dans la mauvaise
plaisanterie et l'autre c'est que c'est
vraiment un cas de personnes qui sont
atteintes d'un trouble mental de
chercher à faire du mal ce qu'on appelle
la perversité alors hier comme
aujourd'hui il faut le rappeler le
harcèlement peut avoir des conséquences
lourdes allant parfois jusqu'au suicide
on se rappelle de la jeune dina en
octobre dernier bien sûr voilà pour
l'actualité de cette semaine que s'est
il passé à cette période de l'année à
cette même période de l'année par le
passé eh ben c'est le zapping de
l'inattendu que nous vous proposons
bonjour
le leader de l'iran a demandé aux
musulmans où qu'ils soient dans le monde
entier d'exécuter un écrivain et ses
éditeurs l'homme qui est visé c'est
salman rushdie un écrivain britannique
connue dans le monde entier sa faute il
a écrit un livre qui s'appelle les
versets sataniques qui ne plaît pas à
l'ayatollah de maurice papon est mort
cet après-midi à l'âge de 96 ans dans
une clinique de la région parisienne
maurice papon condamné à dix ans de
réclusion pour complicité de crimes
contre l'humanité avait été remise en
liberté après trois ans d'incarcération
en raison de son état de santé ce sont
deux systèmes aspire en refoulant comme
celui ci constituant un coeur artificiel
qui ont été posés vendredi dernier sur
un malade de 42 ans souffrant de
cardiomyopathie une très grave maladie
cardiaque
quatre jours après l'intervention l'état
du patient est satisfaisant ça y est
quand max hoff a rempli son contrat ce
15 février il n'ya plus officiellement
un seul soldat soviétique en afghanistan
dolly la célèbre brebis anglaise clooney
présentait des défauts de fabrication
outre des anomalies chromosomiques
elle souffrait depuis deux ans
d'arthrose prématurée de la hanche et du
genou trop malade ses créateurs ont donc
décidé de l'euthanasier
six ans après sa naissance
spectaculaire dans sa conception
l'atomium se voulait à l'époque le
symbole de la science et du progrès
comme la tour eiffel il était voué à
disparaître mais presque 50 ans et 27
millions d'euros de travaux plus tard il
regarde à nouveau vers l'avenir philippe
candeloro heureux et offre à la france
sa troisième médaille ils s'inclinent
derrière il y as coliques et elvis
stojko
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir et merci
c'est presque une tradition un pendant
la campagne électorale les artistes les
écrivains les sportifs à porter soutien
à un candidat un des choix non dénué
d'intérêt bien sûr mais avec quelles
conséquences pour les candidats un bon
chanteur apporte-t-il des voix en tout
cas géraldine ces engagements ont évolué
au fil des campagnes effectivement et
cette année les artistes sont vraiment
peu nombreux à afficher publiquement
leur soutien à un ou une candidate
voilée vous dire ça va venir
mais vraiment ils sont pas nombreux on
peut par exemple citer juliette binoche
qui s'est dit être derrière christiane
taubira ou encore alain delon derrière
valérie pécresse ou encore philippe
chevallier des chevalier laspalès pour
marine le pen mais voilà si c'est quand
même assez rare c'est plus le temps des
grands meetings avec vraiment une foule
d'artistes parce que si on remonte dans
le temps si on regarde les archives
cette alliance artistes candidats était
légion c'est une tradition au parti
communiste
des artistes engagés aux côtés des
candidats simone signoret jean ferrat
pablo picasso ou encore louis aragon
notre parti ce qu'il est devenu
doit beaucoup
à thônes activités dans tous ses aspects
mais dès la campagne de 1974 un candidat
veut lui aussi des vedettes à ses côtés
c'est valéry giscard d'estaing inspiré
des campagnes présidentielles
américaines il veut que ça brille il
réunit alors les stars du moment
mireille mathieu louis de funès ou
encore alain delon un mélange des genres
qui ne plaisait pas forcément aux
téléspectateurs c'est l'histoire des
américains qui sentent encore beaucoup
plus engagé que nous on est à porte à
les artistes prennent un engagement pour
pour un parti pour un président enfin
pour pour un candidat excusez moi je
cherchais mon capitaine non mais écoutez
c'est peut-être atroce pour vous mais
moi je trouve c'est une image charmante
moi je fais tout changer parce qu'on va
faire pareil en france
raté plus les années passent et plus les
campagnes se pare de paillettes je
m'appelle renault je suis chanteur
énervant je suis donné soutenir la
candidature de françois mitterrand
surtout pour le parti socialiste où les
chanteurs et acteurs s'affiche auprès de
françois mitterrand c'était une soirée
très branchés comme on dit les vedettes
du ps sont restées discrètes hier soir
la parole était aux artistes considère
que ce monsieur françois mitterrand me
semble pour le moment jusqu'à preuve du
contraire le mieux répondre à ce que je
ce dont je rêve ou ce que j'espère mais
la droite et le centre ne sont pas en
reste alain delon reçoit dans son salon
pour parler de raymond barre candidat
udf moi je peux vous dire pourquoi
pourquoi raymond bah ouais et va même
jusqu'à faire son clip de campagne
officielle pour l'élection de 1988 le 24
avril prochain quand vous placerez votre
bulletin dans l'urne je sais que vous
penserez à l'avenir et surtout l'avenir
des jeunes mais en votant pour raymond
barre une chose est sûre vous penserez
d'abord à l'avenir de la france campagne
de 1995 les vedettes sont toujours là
line renaud soutient jacques chirac
croiser les doigts pour la france parce
que
ça serait le bon choix les journalistes
eux commencent à critiquer ce mélange
des genres un comité de soutien
tellement médiatique qu'on se serait cru
sur la croisette des soutiens artistique
pour en dire plus sur sa personnalité
pour attirer des électeurs pour gagner
en sympathie une communication
politicienne qui va être utilisé à
outrance par nicolas sarkozy en 2007
[Musique]
ce ne sont plus les vedettes qui
viennent à la politique mais les
candidats qui font appel à eux dans un
but électoraliste il sort de sa botte le
rappeur doc gynéco approche pipoles pour
draguer les jeunes électeurs et ce qu'il
représente pour nicolas sarkozy bien
[Musique]
un avis avant tout me est aussi
quelqu'un qui m'a dit penser un petit
maître à penser cette campagne que les
médias qualifieront de bibi aura des
répercussions pour ces artistes qui ont
soutenu nicolas sarkozy comme faudel
concerts annulés carrière brisée ou
encore doc gynéco il revenait sur cet
engagement dix ans après pour moi c'est
une expérience mais vis-à-vis du public
ça peut être une erreur voilà doc gynéco
dix ans après parle d'erreur alors tout
ça pourquoi est-ce que s'afficher avec
une vedette fait vraiment gagner des
voix en 2007 on le voit sur ces archives
lors de cette campagne bling-bling jean
marc lech co fondateur de l'ipsos
répondez à cette question au moment du
vote l'impact des stars seraient quasi
nul selon ce spécialiste des sondages
ils réfléchissent avec des 10 ans 15 ans
de retard sur l'évolution de la société
française qui n'a plus aujourd'hui avec
l'autorité artistique culturel ou
médiatique
une relation d'obéissance on va dire on
voit la ficelle et plus on voit johnny
plus on voit la ficelle sarkozy alors la
ficelle est tellement grosse que ça peut
même faire l'effet inverse effectivement
et en 2016 lors de la dernière campagne
les français ont été interrogés sur ce
lien candidats artistes 69% des français
n'accordent aucune importance à ces
soutiens d'artistes donc voilà comme ça
c'est fait pour pas trop de se donner
d'eux-mêmes mais là où c'est intéressant
c'est que pour 71% des français c'est
quand même assez énorme c'est une
mauvaise chose pour un artiste que de
s'engager avec un candidat en campagne
c'est peut-être pour ça que les stars
aujourd'hui se font de plus en plus rare
dans les meetings merci pour ce regard
particulier sur sur les sondages bien
sûr et sur les présidentielles merci
jean françois doridot directeur général
d'ipsos public affairs bonjour bonjour
alors en cette période électorale a les
chiffres des enquêtes d'opinion des
intentions de vote sont bien sûr
omniprésent c'est une période très
importante j'imagine pour vous comment
est-ce que vous gérez ses frénésies
écouter c est en effet une période de
médiatisation qui est très importante et
puis on nous attend quand même au
tournant pour savoir si nos résultats
seront bons le 10 avril même si les
sondages d'opinion et même les sondages
électoraux c'est vraiment la face
immergée de l'iceberg dans un institut
comme ipsos est à peine 5% de l'activité
mais ça ce qu'on imagine que tout le
monde est concentré sur les élections
chez ipsos écoutez ici on et 600 à 700
et des gens qui travaillent sur
l'électoral une dizaine maximum donc
vous voyez on est vraiment sur une
petite partie de l'activité m'ont en
effet c'est très chargé enfin vous en
faites partie donc on vous garde le
travail autour de ces sondages dans les
différentes rédactions n'a jamais eu une
place aussi importante
oui il n'ya qu'à regarder les chiffres
pour comprendre l'ampleur du phénomène
alors selon la commission des sondages
en 1981 111 sondages ont été réalisés
pour l'élection présidentielle pour
celles de 1995 c'était 150 793 pour
celle de 2002 293 en 2007 et ça continue
de grimper un pour atteindre 560 sondage
réalisé en 2017 et il ya un fait la
france est quand même le pays qui
consomme le plus de sondages par
habitant comment est ce qu'on explique
ce phénomène en tout cas cet engouement
pour les sondages en france en effet il
ya une offre médiatique est de plus en
plus importante avec les chaînes
d'information et donc le fait qu'il ya
de plus en plus de comment ils sont
assurés les commandes et puis depuis que
les sondages sont réalisés
par internet le coût d'entrée pour les
instituts de sondage il est moins cher
avant les sondages ils étaient réalisées
au domicile des gens par téléphone il
fallait tout un réseau d'enquêteurs sur
toute la france 200 300 400 enquêteurs
ça avait un certain prix et donc ça ça
abaisser les barrières d'entrée il ya
davantage de sondage on va remonter le
temps des sondages avec ludivine depuis
quand les médias s'intéressent style à
ces sondages alors depuis le début à des
années 60 alors à cette époque les
français sont plus ce sont plusieurs
fois consultés par référendum de quoi
intéresser les pouvoirs publics les
instituts de sondage et la télévision en
1962 par exemple à quelques jours du
référendum pour l'élection du président
de la république au suffrage universel
direct l'ifop menait des enquêtes sur la
politique du général de gaulle alors les
résultats étaient commentées à la
télévision et les journalistes étaient
en quête de pronostic je saint denis
serait pas loyal de vous demander
d'indiquer aux téléspectateurs vos
pronostics pour demain enfin j'espère
que vous accepterez confié quelques uns
d'entre nous pour que nous puissions
vérifier oui très certainement
naturellement vous pouvez l'imaginer
nous avons fait les travaux qui nous
permettent de savoir à trois jours du
référendum et j'insiste bien sur le fait
qu'il ne s'agit absolument pas ne
faisons pas de travaux qui sont des
prédictions mais nous faisons des
travaux qui ont pour but connaître
l'évolution des choses eh bien il est
certain que nous avons trouvés dans
notre dernière enquête des résultats qui
donnent une indication de ce que peuvent
être ou ce que pourront être demain le
pourcentage des oui et des non nous ne
voulons pas influencer les
téléspectateurs et influencer le public
en publiant ses résultats maintenant par
contre tu réellement je serais très
heureux de pouvoir confronter ses
résultats avec la réalité dans deux
jours alors on l'a entendu l influence
des sondages sur l'opinion publique
était déjà évoquée à l'époque on va y
revenir tout à l'heure mais d'abord
j'aimerais m'arrêter sur cette phrase
prononcée à l'époque par le directeur de
l'ifop ils disaient les sondages pour
les sondages il ne s'agit pas de
prédiction soixante ans plus tard est-ce
que cette réalité a été intégrée par
l'opinion publique et par les médias les
sondages ce ne sont pas des prédictions
non ce ne sont pas des prédictions sap a
été totalement intégrée par notamment un
certain nombre de deux commentateurs on
nous parle toujours et les sondages se
trompent six mois dans l'élection ce qui
n'a aucun sens puisqu'il ya une campagne
qui va se dérouler une offre de
candidature qui va qui va s'affiner les
sondages ça permet de comprendre ce qui
se passe dans l'opinion de comprendre
les dynamiques de campagne de comprendre
et d'objectiver ce que pensent les
françaises sur un certain nombre de
thèmes et d'éviter qu'un certain nombre
de commentateurs de candidats au doigt
mouillé finalement nous disent voilà ce
que pensent les français ça permet quand
même d'objectiver les choses alors un
sondage on le rappelle ainsi une
photographie à un instant t fait sur un
échantillon moi j'aimerais bien vous
nous expliquer ce principe de
l'échantillonnage comment ça fonctionne
un sondage va en fait on essaye de
reproduire une petite france un modèle
réduit de la france d'après les données
qu'on a de l'insee sur des enquêtes on
va dire classique auprès de 1500
personnes par on va essayer de
reproduire une france miniature c'est la
méthode dite des quotas avoir le bon
nombre d'hommes de femmes de jeunes de
personnes un peu plus âgés de profession
de gens qui habitent en occitanie nord
pas de calais ou de gens qui habitent
d'imaginer qu'il veut des grandes
communes 1500 personnes vont finalement
refléter l'opinion de 66 millions de
personnes c'est dingue alors les
refléter avec des marges d'erreur
avec l'arrivée donc des sondages on va
revenir un petit peu dans le passé l
arrivée des sondages donc dans la sphère
médiatique dans les années 60 70 des
critiques ont aussi émergé une défiance
s'installe rapidement elle s'illustre
avec cet échange que je voulais vous
montrer en 1973 entre le journaliste
roger gicquel et jean stoetzel
l'inventeur des sondages d'opinion en
france
est ce que vous avez eu la curiosité
d'effectuer un sondage sur la
crédibilité du sondage autrement dit
avez vous posé la question suivante
pensez vous que les sondages puisse être
ou non manipulée
est ce que vous croyez que sont l'ins
ont manipulé je croyais que
personnellement je plaque non moi je ne
sers à rien le secteur inondable
l'opinion publique y pense ce n'est pas
raisonnable
à supposer que les sondages soient
manipulés
étant donné que très souvent les
dernières observations sont très
voisines du résultat effectif du [ __ ]
cela voudrait dire que
le sondage a été manipulé si
astucieusement que c'est très exactement
la différence entre ce qui était la
vérité et qui a été changée qui a
produit l'effet que vous observez le
jour de l'élection je pense et rillieux
tout le monde sait qu'il suffit d'un
faible déplacement de voix quelquefois
pour assurer une élection il suffirait
donc d'une très légère manipulation
alors roger gicquel on le voit un ne
lâche pas le morceau l'idée que les
sondages pourrait manipuler l'opinion
publique l'influencé c'est une idée qui
perdure aujourd'hui est ce que les
sondages jean françois doridot oreste
pouvoir alors ces deux choses
différentes manipulée et influencée
manipuler non il faut rappeler que les
instituts de sondage sur des entreprises
privées qui si elle se trompe sur les
dernières intentions de vote un ou deux
jours avant le scrutin en paye les
conséquences notamment par exemple ipsos
qui est cotée qui est cotée en bourse
influencée
le choix de vote d'un certain nombre de
français oui oui mais comme d'autres
éléments comme d'autres chiffres comme
le taux d'inflation comme le taux de
chômage comme l'actualité du moment un
fait divers mais le fait qu'ils
utilisent que certains utilisent les
sondages pour former leurs votes ne me
paraît pas un problème que des gens
réfléchissent et ce disque finalement il
vaut mieux voter pour tel candidat pour
essayer de faire en sorte que tel autre
n'arrive pas au second tour je ne vois
pas en quoi c'est un problème vous
parliez tout à l'heure de la de la marge
d'erreur comment est-ce qu'on apprécie
cette marche erreur et quelle est cette
marge d'erreur alors la marge d'erreur
elle dépend du nombre de personnes qu'on
interroge plus on interroge de jambes
plus elle est faible et aussi du
pourcentage qu'on recueille en gros sur
un sondage on parlait tout à l'heure
1500 personnes sur des voiliers bien
quoi je fais allusion sur des candidats
qui seront autour de 15% on a une marge
d'erreur de deux points un donc un 15 c
en fait entre 1,17 et intra c'était une
loi statistique ça veut dire que si on
reproduisait le même sondage avec le
même type d'échantillon pas les mêmes
personnes mais le même type
d'échantillon au même moment on
trouverait des résultats sensiblement
différents ce qui explique des fois
parfois les différences entre les
instituts et cette notion de marche des
rares 1d x s'arrête pour l'opinion
publique ça peut être une notion
finalement un peu floue et c'est ce qui
pourrait peut-être expliquer cette
défiance en tout cas en novembre dernier
une enquête révélait que 64% des
personnes sondés estimaient que les
sondages sur les intentions de vote
n'étaient pas fiables est ce qu'il n'ya
pas on pourrait se poser la question une
certaine lassitude est ce que les
sondages sont fiables ou pas fiable la
plupart du temps en fait il ne se trompe
pas mais il ya des fragilités proche de
nous y est le breakbeat trump en 2002
rappelez-vous la surprise on se rappelle
la surprise chirac le pen au second tour
a aussi marqué les esprits pareil en
1995 les jeux étaient faits les sondages
annonçaient un second tour entre les
deux rivaux de droite chirac balladur le
match se jouera finalement entre le
candidat de gauche lionel jospin et
jacques chirac et le soir des résultats
nicolas sarkozy porte parole à l'époque
d'edouard balladur pointait la
responsabilité des sondages je tiendrai
deux conclusions
la première c'est que c'est une
formidable défaite pour les instituts de
sondage je veux dire les choses très
simplement et je crois que nous
pourrions tous être d'accord
depuis un mois et notamment l'institut
qui travaillaient france télévisions bv
un essai de raconter aux français que
l'élection ait joué qu'il y aura des
écarts formidable on ad'un paniz et les
français avec cela je poserai le
problème et j'estime que nous serons un
grand nombre à poser de problème de la
présence des sondages si près d'une
élection monsieur bilalian quel que soit
l'intérêt ou non un problème est posé la
première victime ce soir ce sont des
instituts de sondage qui ont été dans
leur immense majorité complètement
balayées dans leurs prévisions
lui répondez quoi à nicolas sarkozy à la
fois qu'il a raison qu'il a tort il a
raison en effet les instituts de sondage
avait vu lionel jospin plutôt deuxième
il est premier en revanche il a tort
parce que rappelez vous cette campagne
l'utilité des sondages en descendre en
janvier on nous dit c'est plié c'est
terminé pour jacques chirac il a dix
points de retard serait douar balladur
il ne pourra pas les refaire là elle le
second tour opposera edouard balladur à
lionel jospin et finalement
janvier-février enquête après enquête on
voit que edouard balladur rade son début
de campagne que jacques chirac réoriente
sa campagne sur la fracture sociale les
courbe s'inverse et l'intérêt là vous le
comprenez bien des instituts de sondages
et des enquêtes c'est qu'elles ont
montré qu'il y avait cette inversion et
que s'il n'y avait pas eu ces enquêtes
on aurait continué à dire que jacques
chirac avait définitivement perdu cette
élection alors un candidat à la
présidentielle a justement évoqué cette
ambiguïté à la télévision à des
politiques envers les sondages c'était
françois bayrou en 2002
évidemment quand vous vous déplacez la
première question c'est monsieur bayrou
alors les sondages
franchement populaire si pensez-vous
quotidiennement ça vous pèse
vêtements c'est fait pour ça donc
celui qui vous dit qu'il regarde enfin
que que les sondages ne l'atteignent pas
cessé pour vous atteint simplement faut
savoir si vous cédez ou pas alors ça a
le mérite d'être clair le poids des
sondages sur les politiques est
indéniable est ce qu'on pourra aller
jusqu'à dire qu'il participe de la
réussite ou de la défaite d'un candidat
ils peuvent voir un rôle dans la
sélection plutôt dans la sélection des
candidats ont annoncé parce que ségolène
royal après sa victoire en 2004 aux
régionales a commencé à émerger dans les
enquêtes d'opinion et plus des enquêtes
de popularité qu'elle est devenue
qu'elle s'est imposée comme la candidate
des socialistes en 2007 mais l'opinion
ne suis pas forcément les sondages
regardez il ya encore deux mois qui
était le favori c'est et xavier bertrand
dans les sondages qui paraissait le
mieux placé pour battre emmanuel macron
et pourtant c'est valérie pécresse qui a
été désignée donc l'affluence des
sondages ça se discute dernière question
durant cette campagne présidentielle le
quotidien régional ouest france a décidé
de ne pas piller publié deux sondages le
journal breton des noms je cite la
dangerosité de l'omniprésence des
sondages pour la démocratie question
est-ce que trop de sondages tube
sondages on pourrait dire oui mais en
fait le sondage est complémentaire c'est
à dire que ouest france aurait pu à la
fois publié quelques sondages et faire
des enquêtes approfondies avec du
journalisme de terrain pour illustrer
ces sondages donc en fait c'est pas l'un
ou l'autre c'est les deux c'est une
c'est une clé d'explication qui à mon
avis est remplaçable mais ce n'est pas
la seule jean françois doridot merci en
tout cas pour cet éclairage sur sur les
sondages et cette visite des intentions
de vote très intéressante et merci à
vous ludivine on va se quitter avec
notre traditionnel pépites à cette
semaine nous vous proposons un
micro-trottoir politique réalisé en 1977
par le célèbre gérard pas bio avec des
réponses toujours très étonnante
regardez écoutez
vous connaissez le rpr de quoi s'agit-il
d'un train qui menace si vous connaissez
le pc
seront les pc à deux tranchants qu'est
ce que c'est que le resserrement des
alliances il ya des cas quand ça vous
gêne le doigt qu'elle a que le var
l'alliance est trop petit ça vous gêne
car nous fait même malte les dissensions
intestines il ya eu pas mal de
dissensions intestines ces derniers
temps alors de quoi s'agit-il maxi quais
des gares oui qu'on a dans le ventre
vous voyez ce que c'est l'ouverture à
gauche bien sûr comme ça m'a enlevé mon
veston mais on fera ça sa fragrance
confrères ça sera ça l'ouverture à
gauche et vous n'êtes pas spécialement
favorable je suis pas défavorable moi
vous savez nous souhaitons ni habitués
on s'habille qui pourrait la gauche la
droite ou le centre le principal c'est
qu'on puisse fermer nos vêtements
voilà quelques sourires sur la politique
ça fait du bien on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine sur le canal 27 et
toute la semaine sur les réseaux sociaux
ce soit ce dîner ou ce de france info
émission préparée avec les
documentalistes viviane marni emilie
galtier merci à elle et merci à vous
d'être là toutes les semaines
[Musique]